hey everybody Alexa right here with a
GameSpot news update first we had the
book then the game now a movie it looks
like The Witcher is getting a
full-length feature film a movie based
on Andres suppose Keys The Witcher
series is in the works and is slated to
arrive in 2017 American film production
company the Shawn Daniel company
producers of The Mummy series has
announced it will work with Polish
company platies films on the project you
might not know poutine by name but
you're probably familiar with its work
the company produces stunning witcher 3
trailer called the trail and also
created cinematics for halo 5 guardians
among a long list of other projects in a
press release producer said the movie
will start Geralt of Rivia but won't be
a straight adaptation of any of the
novels or games instead it will follow
the themes of the short stories The
Witcher and lesser evil from suppose
he's the last wish collection the film
is expected to be the first in a series
directing the film is tamas Baginski who
earned an Oscar nomination for the 2002
animated film the Cathedral Hollywood
veteran fannia st. John of grim Chicago
Fire and Buffy the Vampire Slayer Fame
is writing the script for the untitled
Witcher film no actors were named in the
announcement The Witcher video games
also based on sakowskis work are
developed by polar studio CD Projekt RED
which doesn't appear to have any
involvement in new movie the latest game
Wild Hunt has sold more than 6 million
copies but a follow-up isn't coming
anytime soon this also isn't the first
stab at a Witcher movie a Polish film
called The Witcher was released in 2001
so do you think they can pull this off
movies based on video games don't have
the best track record but technically
this is based on the book so we'll see
for more on the Witcher you're in the
right place
you